okay I feel I will but not on camera
it's not that kind of show what
sublimation happy welcome to live nation
happy Sunday welcome to another episode
of flight with ever know it's mail time
with Evan
we've got packages to open and we are
excited
[Music]
all right it's been a while since we did
our last meal time Nina's not even
waiting she's already picked up the
first one if you guys want to send me
something we're gonna open up on there
on camera promote your business the link
to started in salsa is in the
description below so looking forward to
opening up what you have this said next
let's kick it off
this is forever no matter for you the
whole thing is some in forever chemical
it's that the idea that you can tell me
none of those and I know I get them from
the letter Wow okay
first up is a letter did you come to
third Oh what is it
it's a crown looking forward to you
being something something something
you've been a great a great look at that
well I can't read it and this hat will
definitely not fit me for the mic the
Teemo Teemo hey you got a hot all right
okay forget it with you well thank you
for the crown what do you got Nina open
it up like a jewelry box all mcmenamy's
business girls specialist strategic
sales consultants all right let's see it
the most team most very excited by this
handmade metal link bracelet with
Tiberian silver clasp XX Debra thank you
follow Debra coupie do cookie do calm
that's cool look at that yeah like this
okay
[Music]
we did it yes
solving problems entrepreneur style team
of solving how these entrepreneurs tile
oh my goodness
this is so exciting ok next version calm
[Music]
we've got design it's a bad material
that's a t-shirt bag looks like the bags
inside it I think if I consider yeah it
looks like this it's a t-shirt obsession
ok ha oh look at this
Evan here is our way to change the world
one person one pair at a time believe
believe you organic you look looking
forward to your top 10 - why you wear on
vision I'm Persian
hungry love from the USA
Christopher alright thank you sir here
we go
this white shorts look at the shorts
with the little pink little pink crest
there and then alright alright these are
like neon green large okay I feel I will
but not on camera it's not that kind of
show
let's try the large see how it go oh
look at the shards look at this DISA
these are some funky shirts he won't
even see you very excited by my new
shirt so these are these are super
comfortable though
super comfortable and they've got a
second layer see you got the layer this
is this is hugs here this is like super
loose on top maybe that's all right is
it comfortable okay next
oh it says thank you Jeffrey Tambor
Sousa opinion oh look at this look at
the back of the card look at this car I
didn't even get to see you okay
the big nation you see look at that
that's cool Hey look before everything
else getting ready is the secret of
success I like it
okay thanks for connecting Lily to me
Lily's my one word coach invested
harro's an entrepreneur I take my
business dippers more seriously I
figured writing is more personal than
email messaging well I'm gonna save this
card and give it to Lily as well thank
you for the low thanks for the love
that's awesome
the next one you should give it to the
kids wait a minute
which one is for Lily do you oh oh yeah
Mariah
suka sent two cards one for me one for
Lily will open up mine will save Lily's
oh it doesn't thank you card thank you
whoa what cards felling that if you're
ever having a bad day just flip this
card over oh you've just been caught
being awesome amazing look at that look
at this other side
you've just been copying awesome keep
that stuff you are an amazing person
that we forget it but there's no name on
it this [ __ ] you should have an email
thank you so much for for giving me a
session Lily it was very fun and she
helped me up and the Lily the Lily love
is out of control on this Louise get
more something Nina
people confuse Nina and Lily sometimes
and it makes me it mean a very upset
well we are Asian doesn't mean like
Thank You Mariah much love I'll give
Lily hers too next one it's from h1n1
click each one click for no muscles Lily
Elina don't laugh guys it's not funny
it's a book
call the co the official book the
official book of colic Oh
oh wow with a nice nice inscription on
the inside later that wow this is this
is a this is a you guys see it's got
lots of graphics it's the history of
this company I guess all right Thank You
guy links comic oh they push a book
hardcover alright yeah next up coming
from Germany Germany I like it this is
books does meanness in German Wow hold
on I mean happy to support but I can't
reach it
Wow look at look at this look at the
amount of tape on this package but this
is how I would tape it alright alright
look I'm not something the shirt where
did the package go and this bubble wrap
inside Oh Cara
what just be like a book this size or
something yeah
there's two bucks two bucks in a card
okay
two bucks am I tired all right
bhagavad-gita as it is the Bhagavad
Gita's an ancient text that the scribes
had a tense moment wasn't worked into
yoga and my disciplines all right
interesting very cool thank you
another one same guy bold spiritual
vision he built a house in which the
whole world can live namaste you're
having Carmichael I like that
namaste what's music music I like it why
this very invested into my spiritual
journey here look at this paper to the
first page is green the second page is
peach and the third page is yellow I
like it
thank you very much we have to get so
this is to get us into yoga the
spiritual side of yoga is not just some
of the movements but it's the the
breathing's at the CDs - alright thank
you for the book we've got books for
days oh this is David Park we had David
on the channel on the get David on the
channel recently we did a hangout with
him smart couples
yeah investments for couples alright
thanks a lot David
that was a great interview looking
forward to checking out the book - I
thought I guess this big
I got two more books it says put lots of
books you feel like sending me books and
shorts in music and jewelry huh rocking
the rock to the silver key alright
holiday Hey write me I need to know
right huh new book this guy comes up
with a new foot like every week this is
crazy
Ryan man right is the man Ryan is the
man conspiracy all right Thank You Ryan
much appreciate a minute last but not
least priority mail Oh do in an Levitt
box okay you open that when I get this
line then let's throw the like box like
Oh either shoot entrepreneurship
financially look at that that's the
packaging right there that is a
packaging what's inside look at the
identity she's taking out the stuffing
so it doesn't make a mess
Nina what can you clean up
seriously
life is messy me now you know box but
life with Emmet is messy right thank you
later okay thank you
as entrepreneurs it is our desire to
help others fulfill their own
entrepreneurial desires we've been
watching your videos for a year now
thank you for helping us fulfill our
olio olio oh boy oh boy Wow
alright thank you kindly man this will
fit my shorts it's it's full-on summer
near believe nation happy this must be
like a monthly box subscription but they
send you a box of stuff every month
financial freedom
it was Muslim my only card this says it
says CEO but like it's a billion oh it's
a million wait is that million that's a
million CEO million that's the size it
was a small financial freedom I like it
Starbucks missive via via in saqqaq
elegant tough things first leadership
lessons from Silicon Valley's
longest-serving CEO the pendulum oh my
god Hades the haters gonna freak out for
this time you know he's gonna figure
this better
he's still gonna love this pen name it
havens gonna love this pen 100% he's
gonna freak out alright that's it for
this video thank you guys so much for
sending in your stuff if you want us to
open up something from you that's pretty
nice
that's havens if you want us to open up
something from you I get your private
something visual medium or Haven or
email send it to the address in
description any final messages Nina for
believe nation this weekend thank you
for setting the packages here lovely of
you guys yeah whatever you do make sure
you have fun than making cats alright
thanks for watching we believe in you we
hope you continue to in yourself
whatever
[Music]
[Applause]